now another part of the superhero world
that we wanted to weigh in on is the
Henry Cavill saying that despite when we
all thought that he might be done
playing Superman he says now that he
might still play the role this is while
he's promoting his new show The Witcher
which sure looks awesome yeah for me it
was always it was always a target I
always wanted to bring things like this
to to the screen in one way shape or
form and I'm I'm very happy we did and
I'm very happy the Game of Thrones was
such a wonderful success because it does
open the door as you say in the in the
minds of the business people at various
studios to say it can work and we can do
it in the same way that I was always
happy with the success of Marvel because
it meant people wanted to see
superheroes and therefore DC could
thrive as well can you envision any
situation where you would come back to
that role or is it is it it has the door
closed and you can moved on and they've
moved on door hasn't closed I'll leave
it at that
[Music]
the rest of you he talks about what
you're just saying but kind of sci-fi
and having of stories that's what he
kind of says why he loves the genre so
much as well yes so yeah it's you're a
big fan of the superhero world he's like
yeah I mean look at him he looks like so
yeah sure I really liked his work in
Mission Impossible
I think Witcher looks awesome I'm a big
fan of the game and supposedly he's a
huge gamer and he want that's why he
wanted to do Witcher but I mean if I
were that might be like cool great with
Henry Cavill I don't really yeah like I
gather like the some of the movies that
he's been in have been hit and miss but
nothing to do with him he's the great
elemental his sequel yet like is also
really hard if we're to do it's so hard
to do because kryptonite's boring like I
can't watch more kryptonite stuff and
then it's to eat like further his equal
you need to
then it's like people it's exactly what
they're showing people going through
building it's tough to create a human
story
it's kind of it kind of stumbled at the
starting block this whole super grant
thing but when when I interview them for
Man of Steel years ago I have rarely
seen an actor more excited for a project
that they were a part of like he
genuinely was like I'm loving being
Superman this is what I want to do for
the rest of my work right and so I'm not
surprised that he's not like he hasn't
given up yet